if you try to play that game the
competition game
i'm the strongest i'm the best you lose
that game
if you have friends that make you wrong
for changing your life for the better
that's
their issue the truth of life is you can
go anywhere you want you can be
anything that you want you can become
anyone you want to become
at the end of the day the choice is
yours
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos
because you know you've got something
more inside you you've got michael
jordan level genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the five
painful truths that you need to deal
with
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with truth number
one purify your heart set with robin
sharma
the big lie of positive thinking if
positive thinking was the real game
changer
then why do so many people who
think positively and they do their
affirmations
and they read the books and they go to
live events
and they do the online courses and they
meditate and pray and
journal on positive thinking and yet
three days later someone cuts them off
in traffic
and they're expressing road rage or
someone is a little rude to them in a
restaurant
and they feel bad about it for the next
number of weeks or
something doesn't go right at work and
they get aggravated or
irritated or frustrated well that's
because mindset is not
everything heartset is the other
50 percent and heartset as i've
suggested is your emotional life
you see you can have a great psychology
a strong mindset
but if your emotional life is full of
pain if your emotional life
is full of resentment if you haven't
processed
through old heartbreak if you are
full of latent dormant
anger well then you have what i call and
this is really important so write this
down
you have this invisible subconscious
field of hurt suppressed deep
within you and so you are trying to
optimize
your mindset by reading the books and
being around
positive people and seeing the blessing
amidst difficulty and doing all the
things
that you're encouraged to do but you're
not
dealing with the second piece which is
your heart set and so you've got this
field of hurt that is suppressed
deep within your subconscious so you
don't
even know about it now this is really
important
that field of toxicity that field of
hurt
that old pain that old anger that
old frustration from all the
things that have you've experienced in a
human life that
hurts you it's it's
it's invisible and yet the people around
you are feeling it
it's creating self-sabotage because your
psychology is saying go out and be
legendary and yet this invisible field
of
hurt is saying i'm sad
i'm angry i'm not enough there's all
this self-hatred
and so this is the missing link to
personal transformation because
we get it intellectually in terms of our
mindset
we know what we need to do to be
exponentially creative productive elite
performance
performers to have lives full of
prosperity but we get it
in the head and we miss it in the heart
because society does not teach us how
to purify our heart sets truth number
two
don't play to compete with grant cardone
i'm going to tell you a really really
important lesson
do not try
the competition thing it's overrated and
it doesn't work and i'm going to prove
it to you right here in a second
okay this is a private what's called an
fbo
everybody that flies in here owns their
own aircraft
so you don't want to try to be the
biggest jet okay
you don't want to try to beat up most
money you don't want to try to be the
like the best of the best they'll always
be somebody faster
and stronger and richer okay don't play
the game
oh i gotta be number one what does that
even mean man
i gotta be the biggest what does that
even mean i gotta have the biggest car
the biggest watch the hottest chip
what does that mean it's a game you
cannot win at okay
you will get your brains handed to you
i'm going to show you what i mean right
here in a second
that's laying right there that's a
little leerjet right there i think it's
a little leer of phenom i don't have all
my jets right
okay i don't know that's you can buy
that plane for about 800 grand
right next to it little bigger
look what's rolling up right here a
little challenger
we got a little gulf stream four right
there
that that's leaks 13. don't try to play
the game
i'm the biggest that's stupid it's a
stupid game okay
it's a loser's game man i'm going to
show you some equipment out here
because anybody like here's a little
phenom 100.
it blames about 5 million bucks great
plane faster
fast so fast seat seven people okay
maybe four or five million bucks great
plane great starter plane
look at this see that right out there
that's a 20 passenger jet right there
okay now notice what's right next to it
john
okay that's a 727 that a hotel owned
if you try to play that game the
competition game
i'm the strongest i'm the best you lose
that game
you got to find what you need in life
what's enough for you you guys got to
define that
i can't define it for you most people
are coming up short on that game
but there's a lot of other people that
are making the mistake when they get in
the game and they start playing
they got to keep reaching not because
they need it
but because their ego is like oh i got
to be the biggest
and you know what you are you're gonna
turn into it
like that a hotel owns that that plane's
probably 200 million dollars back there
the point is don't play i gotta be the
strongest because sooner or later you
won't be
find out what you need look look look
the ass on that plane over there hey
look at my little plane look at my
little plane
see you're like man grant man man your
little plane
and now flash over to this one
see if i'm doing a comparison thing the
competition thing it's a loser's game
look at that thing flying in here can
you get that
[Music]
dude a guy told me once he was flying
into new york
he landed his plane he's like man i
thought i was a i thought i was hot
until i hit this freaking airport in
teeterboro i said dude why don't you
still feel like hot
because my plane's smaller than
airplanes i'm like
shame on you bro for playing a game you
can't win that
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here truth
number three categorize your friends
with mel robbins
if you have friends that make you wrong
for changing your life for the better
that's
their issue it's not yours and so you
got to untangle the fact that they have
baggage about getting in shape or they
have baggage about going to
the bar that's theirs and it has nothing
to do with the decisions that you're
making
so if your friends in general give you
blowback for changing for the better
what you need to say in the back of your
mind is interesting they're obviously
very conflicted about their choice to go
to the bar and drink every night but
that has nothing
to do with me here's the other thing you
can do if they start to make you wrong
you can say well you want to go to
planet fitness with me instead it
doesn't sound like you want to be at the
bar
so that said let me talk to you a little
bit about friends
friends are people that you care about
and i have this test i call it
the funeral test if somebody in your
life were to die
ask yourself would i go to their funeral
if the answer is yes
they're a friend of yours that's the
test for whether or not in my opinion
someone is a friend because it means you
care about them now here's the other
thing about friendship that i want you
to understand
you can care about somebody and not like
hanging out with them
and that's the situation that you're in
right now
that you have plenty of friends that you
care about if they were to die you would
go to their funeral if they needed you
you would be there if
you saw them you'd be happy to see them
but you don't
like to hang out with them the other
thing that i want you to think about
is that and that's okay that's like a
normal part of friendship
and the reason why that's a normal part
of friendship is because one of the
things that we know about life is that
you're always going to be changing
in the old pattern and the old chapter
you had certain patterns right in the
old chapter of your life you would go to
the bar and drink you would go to the
store and spend money you didn't have
you're in a new chapter now and so you
have different patterns
when your life takes on different
patterns whether it's you're no longer
going to the bar
you're going to the gym the pattern
might even be that one of your kids is
playing with a different soccer team or
maybe you've moved to a different street
in your town
when the patterns change so will your
circle of friends
it's a fact of life but that doesn't
mean your old friends the ones that you
used to drink with aren't friends
anymore
it just means that you don't want to
hang out with them you still care about
them
but you don't like doing what they do
the patterns have changed for a long
time
i had a lot of drama around this until i
realized that it's not
personal it's not personal that you
don't want to hang out with them
patterns in your life have simply
changed the final thing that i want to
leave you with
that may also help you is that remember
i've given you the funeral test
if you'd go to their funeral they're
definitely a friend it means you care
about them but you might not like
hanging out with them that much and
that's cool
that's normal the other thing that i
want you to think about when it comes to
friendships is you can typically put
friends
into three buckets you got friends for a
reason you got friends for a
season and you have friends for a
lifetime and one of the interesting
things that i know about my own life is
that as the patterns of my life
change so do the friends that i hang out
with more frequently
and i also believe that as you change
and the patterns in your life change
people show up in your life for a reason
the right people will show up when you
start going to the gym
the right people that you need for the
pattern that you're in right now will
start showing up when you're
working on your project instead of
shopping and it's exactly the kind of
people that you need
they're there for a reason and the
friends of yours that are friends of
yours for a lifetime i bet you don't
hang out with them that much at all
anyway
but i bet they're the first person that
you call when you need to talk to
somebody about somebody important
those are the friends for a lifetime and
those folks that are still sitting at
the bar and love to blow money that they
don't have
those were friends for a season so if
you're wondering how to cope with
feeling guilty about distancing yourself
and if you're wondering how to stop
feeling like a bad and unloyal friend
understand this friendship it's really
not about you
it's about the category in which people
fit in
depending upon what pattern and what
chapter of your life that you're in
that's it like lose the drama about it
the friends at the bar
are friends for a season the people that
are going to show up when you start
going to the gym
are friends for a reason and the people
that you need to call whenever you've
got a problem
they're friends for a lifetime and
they're always going to be there truth
number four
overcome doubt and failure with lisa
nichols
what i know is i've had many many
moments
of doubt i've had
tons of moments of feeling like i failed
i've had more moments of loss than i
care to remember
and i love the question what do i do
um to push past those and and there's no
i don't know if you can tell
but i don't ever prepare an answer for
your questions
i simply see what comes up because
that's what you're here for
you're here for a conversation with a
sister friend
authentic truthful conversation so when
you ask the question what do i do
uh when it feels like i failed when i
feel like i've lost
or i have moments of doubt um
i do a few things so let's talk about
when i have doubt because doubt normally
happens before failure
so because doubt is in the planning and
what i realize is doubt is like fear for
me
and i use doubt and fear in the same way
so
doubt feeds me the information that
i don't have enough information it it
so let me say that again doubt feeds me
with the insight
that i don't have enough information
because if i'm doubting
the idea i'm doubting the direction
i'm doubting the strategy or the plan
then i realize that i don't have enough
information to get me to a very clear
no sometimes heck no
or h no or yes
heck yes h yes right
doubt says i don't know enough i don't
know enough
doubt about any anything anyone
doubt about a business plan doubt about
a direction in your life or doubt about
a person
and sometimes you can gather all the
information you can
and then the rest is blind
unwavering faith there's two things that
can dissipate doubt
collect more information and know when
it's time to lean on your faith
but when you lean on your faith is
because you're moving
in a direction where you can say i know
like i know like i know i'm supposed to
be in this direction
a lot of times when people pull on their
lean into their intuitive calling their
intuitive pull
and they're going in a direction they
know they should go in but they're
doubtful of what's in that direction
it's because
to me you couple an intuitive movement
with a
solid plan when you have both of those
man you win like you win like you win or
at least you cannot lose
because you took what felt right and you
put a solid plan under
the mistake i see a lot of people make
is that they're so in
they're so engaged in the intuitive pull
that it feels good that they think that
feeling good is enough
no you need to make a plan how many
hours a day are you going to
create the infrastructure under that
feel-good feeling because i guarantee
you
if you don't put enough action enough
consistency and a strong enough strategy
under something that feels good it ain't
gonna feel good for long
and that's a relationship too you got a
plan i
the best thing i heard when with a
therapist was
you gotta plan for the fight not not
assume we're never gonna fight
you gotta plan for the fight as a matter
of fact you gotta set guidelines on the
fight
oh when i first heard i thought what are
you talking about
quit calling into existence a fight and
then i live long enough
that was in my early 20s by the way i
lived long enough
was in enough relationships friendship
family and romantic
to realize no there's a thing called
healthy disruption healthy conflict i
never thought that there was such a
thing called healthy conflict
if you don't engage in healthy conflict
which means it's absolutely okay to
disagree
matter of fact it's necessary to
disagree because then we find how we
communicate how we engage
how we give and take how we expand and
contract how we ebb and flow
how we compromise how we we you find
yourself
out inside conflict and side stretch
inside failure inside setback you
discover who you are and more
importantly
who you have the opportunity to become
either you show up in such a way you go
man i surprised myself i didn't know i
could do that i can i can rise above
cancer like that i don't know i can rise
above illness
or above breakdown or above setback like
that wow
okay or i set down on myself
i gave up i got hooked in being right
and being in control
and i ran away from the relationship too
fast
i i stopped it too fast i allowed a
speed bump
in this relationship to become a stop
sign it wasn't a stop sign to begin with
it was a speed bump it was a hiccup it
was a moment of
of discovery it was a moment of discord
it was a moment of disruption
and i allowed what was supposed to only
be a speed bump
to turn into a stop sign
i only know that in such detail because
i've done that myself
[Music]
here's the other thing is that when
you've managed doubt
with the things i just mentioned and you
leap
and you jump and you jump with the
intention to fly
and you fail be willing to fail
but don't fail and just fall
because if you fail and just fall all
you're going to do from that point
is collect evidence why you should never
leap again and truth number five the
last home before a very special bonus
clip is free
your mind with tom bilyeu as friends
kafka said
you are free that is why you
are lost look around you there are no
guard rails on your life
the reality is that people have tried to
paint a picture for you that says that
there are certain things that are right
they've tried to paint a world for you
that has a path
well laid for it for you to follow go to
school
get good grades get a degree get a job
retire
that's the plan that everybody wants you
to believe
is really the plan but the reality is
that you are free to choose anything you
want the reality is you can go in any
path
you want the reality is that path is an
illusion the truth of life is you can go
anywhere you want you can be anything
that you want you can become
anyone you want to become at the end of
the day
the choice is yours at the end of the
day you get to construct yourself you
get to decide what it is that you want
to believe as long as you're not
violating the laws of physics
even physics is a game of maybe even
physics is uncertain and unknown
at the end of the day everything you get
to do you get to choose you get to
create you get to build something that
you want to be
and in that that's where people get lost
they don't understand that the control
is theirs they're lost because they
think there's a path they think there's
a way forward and emotionally it doesn't
resonate emotionally they're unable to
make it feel real because it doesn't
feel real they feel lost
they're unsure they don't know where to
go or who to become or even who
they are and that sense of being lost
comes from the freedom of being able to
choose anything you want
but no one told you that you could
choose
but as tupac shakur said reality is
wrong
dreams are for real
it's the dream that you want to focus on
the dream is your ability to construct
that path
the dream is you saying this is the way
that i want to walk the dream is you
saying all of this nothingness all of
this mass confusion all of this
probability
and uncertainty i am going to manifest
something real and concrete and
directional
in my life i choose to be who i am
i choose to be who i become i choose to
build
something with my hands to create
something that has never been seen
before to do
something that people have never done
before to believe in things that other
people cannot see
that dream
is my reality that dream is what i'm
going to bring into existence
that dream is the thing that i believe
in
[Music]
and in believing in that dream and
building that path and finding out and
deciding
who you want to be
[Music]
for the first time you will find
yourself
in yourself becoming
so go become what you want to be
don't worry about walking somebody
else's path
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you just get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
got to take action
but when you get motivated and then you
create a specific plan of action for
when
and how you're going to do it your
number jumps from 35
to 91 percent chance of following
through and when you commit to somebody
else
like posting down here in the comments
below that number jumps to 95 percent
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so you
can follow through and i can celebrate
you
if you're not happy it's because you're
not serving period if you keep waking up
every day and feeling like today doesn't
matter that it's not going to serve
anybody then you won't be happy
i think this is unfortunately where so
many people are you wake up and you feel
like
i'm not going to make anything today
that matters nobody cares if i show up
the work i'm about to do is not
meaningful that's the path down to
depression
meanwhile if you do wake up and feel
like today matters i'm going to make
something that will
serve somebody else touch somebody's
life whether it's the world
or just one person's life if you feel
like today is going to matter
to somebody else like what you're going
to make today will matter
will touch at least one human life
you're gonna wake up a lot happier
a lot more fulfilled and with a lot more
purpose
i look at this i'm i'm here making
videos
on on a winter day here in toronto
canada
making videos just talking to my phone
and even though i'm just by myself well
i'm not quite by myself i've got nina
hey nina
i'm just talking to my phone but i feel
like what i'm making is gonna
hopefully touch you that i'm not just
talking into my phone that i'm talking
into
the world and maybe this video blows up
and gets a million views or maybe
eight people see it but the intention
going in is that today is gonna matter
when i woke up this morning
it's a tuesday morning when i when i
make videos
tuesday's my youtube day i look at my
calendar i see what's on there like i'm
gonna make
videos today that are going to touch
somebody's life
and some of them do blow up maybe we've
got 400 million views on a channel
and some of them don't go very far and
that's okay too
people ask me how do i stay so
consistent how do i how have i made
videos
i've been making videos since april 2009
been making a video at least one video a
day
for the past i don't know seven years
how do i stay consistent how do i stay
on it
because it's serving even though it's
just me talking to a phone or talking to
camera there's no
audience it's serving at least i feel
like it's serving
and that's the difference right if
you're
making something every day you may not
always get the end result
right a lot of times if you're making a
product
it may take you weeks or months to
actually get something out
to the market before you can actually
give it to somebody and see the reaction
but how do you feel about it the problem
is the feeling
you don't feel like it really matters
and if you feel like it doesn't really
matter
you won't show up as your best self you
won't put in the energy you won't put in
the effort
and you're going to slowly slip into a
really negative spot that's why so many
people are depressed
so you have to be able to connect what
you're working on
to serving others period it's why i
wrote built to serve you
so how do you do it right how do you
actually connect purpose how do you
actually serve well that's why i wrote
built to serve and
and super quick there's a three-step
process that guide people through it's
the who the why and the how
and the who is to figure out your most
important core value mine is believe
what's yours you know if i'm not happy
it's because there's not enough belief
in my life either in myself
lack of self belief or believing in
other people
when you figure out what your most
important core value is your who it
gives you your compass your roadmap for
the rest of your life
i'm gonna believe in people until i'm
until i'm gone i'll be 180 years old
making hologram vr videos or whatever
technologies out there
still trying to believe in other people
so the first step is your who
and if you think about all of the things
that have made you come alive your
favorite movie your favorite teacher
the people in your life who you love the
most to give your energy
there's a common theme between them mine
is believe yours is something else
when you figure that out though it gives
you a lot more clarity a lot more
direction
and a sense of how you're going to serve
right
i serve people by giving them more
belief
that's why i make these videos so who
the next is your why and your why is
your purpose
and your purpose comes from your pain
you want to talk about fulfillment you
want to talk about serving you want to
talk about
living your purpose everybody wants to
serve and help
but the ones will help the most the ones
that will feel the most connected to
are the people who currently are who we
used to be
it's great to buy the buy a coffee you
know for for somebody
behind you in line or when you're
driving like this let somebody else in
front of you those little acts of
kindness that's fantastic and make you
feel
good for the moment but the deep
fulfillment
the deep level of service will come from
seeing somebody in front of you
and seeing yourself in them seeing
yourself from five years ago
and then you talking to them you
uplifting them
you start seeing the hope in their eyes
that light bulb moment for them that
they don't have to stay stuck where
they're at
because of meeting you they can
transform their life they can end up in
a better spot you've given them the hope
and inspiration the way that nobody else
can
when you see somebody like that and you
help them
that's so much deeper that's
real fulfillment and you'll never get
sick of it
[Music]
if you want to learn the seven
fundamental truths that will change
your life check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there but if you're eating
junk and more junk and then pizza and
then burger king and more burgers and
more junk afterwards and then you eat
one piece of broccoli
doesn't mean you're going to be healthy
working out once won't make a big
difference for you